bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés le salon
mondial du tourisme s'ouvre ce jeudi à
paris ce soir nous allons justement en
parler tourisme avec nos invités comment
se porte le secteur en ile-de-france et
dans les yvelines depuis les attentats
les étrangers et les franciliens boot il
notre région quels sont les enjeux et
les perspectives pour cette année et
plus généralement pour le tourisme dans
le département
pour répondre à ces questions autour de
la table fabrice watts directeur
d'exploitation de france miniature à
elancourt pire taux n'a dit ni directeur
commercial tourisme international de one
nacion magasin de déstockage aux
clayes-sous-bois en face de vous
laetitia la boutique responsable d'une
agence de voyage à montigny le
bretonneux agissent voyage
et puis ambroise graffin directeur de
l'espace rambouillet un parc de loisirs
en action dans le cid yvelines
bonsoir à vous quatre avant de vous
donner à chacun la parole quelques
chiffres pour comprendre le poids du
tourisme en ile de france et dans le
département évidemment la région
parisienne est la première de france
avec et 46 millions de visiteurs vous le
voyez à l'antenne cinq cent mille
emplois directs et indirects les
yvelines c'est un peu plus de 9 millions
de visiteurs l'an passé avec le domaine
de versailles
évidemment comme principal site
touristique il représente à lui tout
seul les deux tiers du nombre total de
visiteurs et finalement l'année 2015 a
été une année tristement exceptionnel en
raison des attentats de janvier de
novembre dernier
c'est pourtant une année plutôt stable
pour le tourisme à en croire sylvie
l'ona directrice est divine tourisme ont
l'écoutent
l'effet est absolument immédiat un cd le
lendemain perte de fréquentation un peu
partout au château ça s'est vu tout de
suite d'ailleurs le lendemain des
attentats le château était fermée le
samedi 14
ce qu'il faut il fallait éviter les
regroupements de population un peu
partout dont beaucoup d'événements dans
le département et qui était organisée
pour les fêtes de fin d'année ont été
annulés il était organisé par les
mairies notamment beaucoup ont été
annulés effectivement pour des raisons
de sécurité et puis après il y avait la
peur du grand public d'aller dans l'est
dans les sites où il y avait beaucoup de
monde et qui pouvait provoquer un
sentiment d'insécurité donc la
restauration par exemple on a en a
souffert
maintenant comme on est en région
ile-de-france qu'on n'est pas à paris
même où se sont déroulés les attentats
on en a quand même moins souffert et on
a toujours notre clientèle de
franciliens être français qui nous reste
quand même fidèle et les étrangers qui
ne viennent plus du tout nous on en a un
petit peu moins souffert que n'a pu
souffrir le parti alors sylvie lahoun à
nous explique que finalement les sites
yvelinois n'ont pas été non pas connu
une chute importante de leur
fréquentation en 2015 malgré les
attentats vous les acteurs directement
concernés par le tourisme dans le
département qu'est ce que vous en pensez
on commence avec vous ambroise graffin
vous êtes le directeur de l'espace
rambouillet dans le sud du département
donc on va dire même le site le plus
éloigné ici sur plateau de paris est ce
que vous partagez le constat de sylvie
daouda globalement oui après je pense
que chacun a ses spécificités et donc on
pourra voir des réalités différentes et
à l'espace rambouillet fin on a dans
notre clientèle 50% de scolaires donc on
a été impacté sur cette cible là
effectivement pris des mesures de
sécurité exactement donc ça qu'ils ont
gelé les sorties scolaires
donc là on a une légère baisse sur ce
créneau là après ça s'est stabilisé au
niveau grand public
et puis on a développé d'autres créneaux
en fait sur les groupes d'entreprises
notamment groupe d'adultes ou là tout ce
qui en fait calme nature découvertes
métier ça marche très bien et l'image
globale du département du département
vers fin prend bien coin sabri soit pour
le parc france miniature situent elles
encourent les visiteurs qu'ils soient
français ou étrangers sont ils plus
réticents se déplacer par exemple dans
un parc
d'attraction comme le vôtre si on prend
l'exemple de 2015 pour france miniature
nous sommes à park saisonniers et on a
la chance d'avoir un calendrier déjà qui
va du mois d'avril jusqu'au début
novembre
donc il a été un petit peu déconnectés
des attentes à 2 janvier ou dut ou du 13
novembre ce qui est quelque part nous
nous a aidés et puis je pense qu'on est
sur l'image d'un site plutôt tranquille
globalement familial qui n'est pas dans
paris intra muros comme le disait sylvie
et ce qui fait que l'année 2015 a été
plutôt correct et vous réouvriront
rappel au mois d'avril est ce que vous
appréhendez l'ouverture pour cette 25ème
année puisque c'est votre anniversaire
votre 25e anniversaire en effet la
préhension non non pas vraiment
aujourd'hui les clients qui commence à
réserver pour france miniature sont dans
des nombre équivalent voire légèrement
supérieurs à ceux qui réservait pour le
mois d'avril de l'année dernière donc je
pense qu'il ya une pression qui est en
train de retomber en banlieue c'est
moins le cas dans paris intra muros je
pense
est-ce qu'ils sont rassurés par les
mesures de sécurité de contrôle des sacs
supplémentaires que nous mettons en
place
peut-être pierre tornade signé comment
vous alors vous c'est particulier
puisque wang chen c'est un centre
commercial tourner vers l'étranger en
tout cas vers les touristes étrangers
quel est le bilan pour vous pour cette
année 2015
alors donc moins méchant paris déjà et
ce nouveau produit donc c'est en face
des croissances donc aujourd'hui on est
un pari est né en décembre 2013
donc aujourd'hui
on a un avantage d'être nouveauté pour
les clients donc aujourd'hui on
enregistre des taux positifs donc sur la
fréquentation touristique
bien évidemment commises et civils en a
on a des flous qui sont moins impactés
qu'à paris donc aujourd'hui
à l'extérieur des paris on n'a pas
enregistré des taux négatifs par rapport
2014 même vous qu'il y avait beaucoup de
visiteurs étrangers qui viennent chez
vous ça il n'y a pas eu d'impact
particulier il ya eu bien évidemment
d'impact donc je vous dis les taux qu'on
a pu enregistrer cet été les tours
extraordinaire décroissance par rapport
à l'été 2014
là on sait moment que c'est le moment le
plus difficile parce que vous savez les
gens qu'ils ont voyagé donc tout de
suite après les attentats il aussi
annulés y perdre et donc des frais donc
aujourd'hui et ils ne vendraient
décembre a tenu bon après tout les gens
qui sont réservées pour les mois de
janvier février
ils ont pu annuler donc leur voyage sans
frais donc c'est là que je vous dis
l'impact est plus fort et c'est là aussi
la saison en plus lasse donc voilà c'est
c'est peut-être là qui est le monde plus
difficile pour nous et on espère bien
donc dans cet été qui va relancer donc
des signaux il existe déjà donc on a des
très belles réservations qui sont à
venir dans les mois prochains
donc on espère effectivement d'aidé
continuent à avoir ce type des
réservations laetitia la boutique en
tant que l'experte du tourisme et des
loisirs vous dirigez je le rappelle une
agence de voyages
ça fait longtemps que vous êtes
également basé sur saint quentin vous
vendez des voyages à l'étranger
est-ce que aussi les attentes en des
répercussions sur les gens de saint
quentin qui souhaitent partir à
l'étranger aussi est-ce que ça peut
avoir un impact
alors c'est vrai qu'à l' inverse de 17
personnes qui sont présentes nous on
envoie les yvelinois plus à l'étranger
et on a senti effectivement une baisse
après les attentats juste après de
fréquentation dans l' agence parce que
les gens restés chez eux en attente en
attente de voir ce qui pouvait se passer
encore savoir s'ils pouvaient reprendre
l'avion savoir si des mesures de
sécurité étaient réellement mise en
place voilà savoir si tout était bien en
ordre pour qu'ils puissent effectivement
voyager dans de bonnes conditions
donc on a eu une baisse de demande
juste après les attentats après janvier
les fêtes ont passé je pense que les
gens n'oublient pas mais malgré tout on
essaye de se reprocher un petit peu avec
le printemps les beaux jours qui vont
arriver donc janvier les gens sont venus
en agence et ont pensé à partir
effectivement à l'étranger mais ça reste
quand même difficile les les gens ont
quand même des craintes fait alors
l'enjeu aujourd'hui j'imagine pour vous
c'est de faire revenir les gens ont en
tout cas de les pousser à venir encore
plus dans vos lieux touristiques
évidemment l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est la
sécurité également est ce que vous
mettez en place des mesures
particulières on va commencer avec vous
fabrice soit la france miniature est ce
que vous mettez des vous allez mettre en
place des mesures particulières et à
mentir du mois d'avril plus que ce qu'on
vous impose que ce que l'état vous
impose dans les contrôles ordinaire mais
jusqu'à maintenant enfin on nous allons
mettre en place le contrôle des ac à
l'entrée comme l'immense majorité des
sites qui accueillent du public qu'ils
soient culturels de loisirs même
commerciaux donc voilà c'est une mesure
il faut pas si c'était plus que ça parce
qu'après aussi c'est ne pas donner un
côté anxiogène à venir chez vous il faut
pas non plus faut pas bunkeriser on va
dire jours à mieux satisfaire les
demandes qui sont faites voilà de mise
en place de contrôles des sacs et
d'aller un petit peu plus loin en cas de
doute mais les les deux mondes deux ne
vont pas au delà
et nous pensons qu'elles ne sont pas
forcément qui n'est pas forcément
nécessaire d'aller d'aller au-delà
aujourd'hui la même chose à one nation
oui donc bien évidemment on a sécurisé
les cendres est ce qui nous est demandé
aussi par l'état et aujourd'hui les gens
et collabore renvoyé au contraire ils
sont a rassuré de voir tous les mesures
qu'on a mis en place pour pour sécuriser
notre notre centre ça fait une commande
chez vous par exemple il ya un vigile à
chaque en plus et ce don qui les
maintient ling donc et les parkings et à
sécuriser les entrées sécurisé donc avec
tous les contrôles qui nous ont été
demandées et aujourd'hui raymond c'est
rendre dans son commercial voilà on fait
le maximum pour rendre les centres sur
est à nouveau g
j'ai remercié la collaboration des
grilles clients parce que je vous lis se
sont rassurés parce qu'il ya des
contrôles etc
donc tout est fait et tout est dans cet
ordre là est également les rôles c'est
aussi d'être pédagogue à l'étranger donc
d'aller commercialiser les yvelines à
l'étranger et rassurer nos clients voyez
donc aujourd'hui c'est un rôle très
important pour nous ambroise graffin
l'espace rambouillet là aussi j'imagine
que la sécurité on va dire maximum merci
c'est un espace on va dire plus
particulier naturel assez les grands
animaux qui font la sécurité ouais c'est
ça on a briefé les c1 et s'oublier leur
avait dit on leur fait des formations
régulières
plus sérieusement en fait on est on est
surtout en fait sur une surveillance
visuelle accrue on s'est posé la
question effectivement des des fouilles
de sacs etc
et puis est bon pour l'instant l'a pas
mis en place systématiquement quoi on
n'est pas obligé de le faire vous l'avez
on n'est pas obligé de le faire n'est
pas obligée de faire non
en revanche la consigne qu'on avait et
puis c'était vraiment là là qu'on a
suivi vraiment c'est la surveillance
accrue
on vous dit à vos joueurs niveau visuel
voilà vraiment une vigilance supérieure
dans la détection si un comportement
bizarre où les groupes de personnes qui
peuvent nous apparaître un petit peu
surprenant ben on est vraiment beaucoup
plus vigilant là-dessus quoi laetitia la
boutique j'imagine la sécurité ça a
toujours été une priorité pour les
vacanciers est ce que c'est devenu
aujourd'hui presque la priorité numéro 1
ou alors on exagère quand on dit ça a
commencé la priorité numéro un les
légendes et qui
dès qu'ils se dit qu'ils entendent
parler d'un attentat de d'une bombe qui
a explosé dans un pays en particulier
tout de suite ça des répercussions nous
sur les ventes sur la destination et
donc sur la fin sur la sécurité de la
destination
même si c'est pas forcément toujours
dans des endroits très touristique ou
sur les destinations préférées des
français
malgré tout ça a un impact sur l'envié
de voyager
je voudrais je voudrais vous entendre
maintenant sur sur un point de vue un
petit peu plus politique
anne hidalgo la maire de paris et
valérie pécresse la présidente de la
région ile de france se sont rendus
ensemble récemment au japon pour assurer
les japonais david douillet conseiller
régional a reçu lui des professionnels
du tourisme chinois
est-ce que ce soutien politique c'est
quelque chose qui compte pour vous est
ce que c'est important est ce que les
politiques ont un rôle à jouer là-dedans
embrase graffin alors je préfère de
réponse là dessus parce que enfin si je
réponds par rapport à l'espace
rambouillet en fait on est peu touchée
par les visiteurs étrangers
ça représente 1 ou 2% seulement donc en
fête sera pas un impact
après c'est sûr que moi je voyageais pas
mal niveau personnel à l'étranger et
les images ont été assez effrayante et
j'avais les coups de fil enfin j'ai
beaucoup de contacts au brésil notamment
j'avais des coups de téléphone où les
gens me disaient voilà bien chez nous
quoi c'est vrai que c'était assez assez
anxiogène
donc je pense que tout ce qui peut être
fait par les politiques pour défendre
effectivement l'image et puis renforcé
le caractère c'est qu'enfin sécurisé et
je pense que c'est pour rendre positif
pierre tommasini alors vous qui êtes
plus tourner vers l'étranger pour le
coup c'est important que les politiques
viennent en soutien du site heures du du
secteur touristique exclusivement oui
bien sûr donc aujourd'hui que c'est très
très important vous a eu aussi le
ministère donc des affaires étrangères
qui est désormais aussi appris le les
portefeuilles tourisme donc ça c'est un
facteur très important pour nous et pour
développer l'e tourisme français dans
les mondes mais c'est pas que les
politiques mais c'est aussi donc nous
les opérateurs comment arriver à se
fédérer et porter la destination à
l'étranger donc faire la promotion donc
c'est à dire faut être membre d'al ameen
et les politiques de l'aspect donc on va
dire diplomatique et aussi les
professionnels à faire la promotion à
continuer donc l'erreur plus grave
serait d'arrêter de faire de la
promotion à l'étranger
aujourd'hui faut y aller il faut faire
la promotion il faut être pédagogue
expliqué qu'aujourd'hui il faut
retourner à paris ferait tourner dans la
région de l'île de france fabrice soit
vous qui représentez en miniature tous
les monuments français vous avez
forcément un avis sur ce que veut il un
avis alors un peu comme l'espace
rambouillet finalement la clientèle
étrangère les assez peu présente à
france miniature
on a même connu d'ailleurs un léger
rebond en 2015 mais vous allez contre
toutes les analyses effectivement mais
dans des proportions assez faible voilà
on a une pointe à 6 % de clients
étrangers sur l'année 2015 qui est plus
fort que les années précédentes me l'a 6
% des visiteurs france miniature sont
étrangers mais évidemment il est
important de soutenir le tourisme le
tourisme de masse vous avions ces
quelques chiffres leur là pour
l'économie française le tourisme est
aujourd'hui indispensable après pour le
cal france miniature évidemment 6 %
d'étrangers 6 % de clients c'est une
part non négligeable mais ce n'est
qu'une
toute petite partie qui vient de chez
nous et je pense que les démarches
attaque plutôt au tourisme de masse de
grands groupes notre clientèle étrangère
elle est plutôt à titre individuel elle
est très souvent véhiculés c'est pas
tout à fait la clientèle qui vient
jusque jeu laetitia la boutique est ce
que vous disent par exemple je sais pas
vous êtes sur mon contact avec des
collègues à l'étranger même c'est sûr
est ce que comme en bronze raffin il
vous appelle et ils disent que ce qui se
passe bien vite chez nous ou alors pas
tout à fait sans comme non pas encore
mais bon enfin c'est vrai que quand on a
la possibilité enfin on discute et on
rencontre des personnes à l'étranger
effectivement ça arrive moi même que je
parte visiter des hôtels après pour nous
mieux empalot clients donc on discute
avec des interlocuteurs qui font le même
métier que nous et c'est effectivement
ça arrive qu'ils se disent oui la france
était quand même fait partie des pays
les plus visités au monde il ya quelques
temps il ya des des tableaux au niveau
de la sûreté des pays où avec les
attentats qui se sont passés en 2015 où
on a vu des pays auxquels on pensait pas
monté sur l'échelle des pays où on se
sent bien et la france descendent au 63e
rang en termes de sûreté donc c'est vrai
que les étrangers font attention aussi à
ça et oui commence à se poser de plus en
plus de questions et du coup pensé à
aller visiter d'autres pays plutôt que
la france aujourd'hui auxquels ils
n'auraient pas pensé au départ on va
voir si on peut être optimiste pour 2016
je vous propose d'écouter là dessus sur
ce point sylvie léonard la directrice
d'yveline tourisme alors effectivement
ça ne peut que repartir puisque l'effet
attentat a été immédiat quasiment et
comme les attentats maintenant
son passé il ya quelques mois l'activité
repart on peut pas rester chez soi
éternellement donc l'activité
touristique effectivement repart
maintenant on ne peut pas dire quelles
seront les perspectives de l'année parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de facteurs qui existe
pour les sites touristiques il ya
toujours ce fameux facteur météo on a
beaucoup de sites touristiques qui sont
des sites d'extérieur on a les
principaux sites touristiques qui
représente un million cent mille
visiteurs qui sont des sites d'extérieur
donc c'est un gros pourcentage de volume
de clientèle des sites touristiques qui
sont 3 millions en neuf donc en
pourcentage c'est beaucoup et ils sont
tributaires de la météo alors cela les
perspectives tant que donc c'est pas
passé on peut pas le dire maintenant il
faudrait pas non plus qu'ils aient
d'autres attentats qui se déroule parce
que là ça serait de nouveau une
catastrophe
maintenant si les choses continuent
telles qu'elles sont engagés aujourd'hui
on peut imaginer que l'année 2016 ne
sera pas une mauvaise année
maintenant on peut on ne peut jamais
déterminés à coup sûr que ça sera le cas
alors sylvie la hoya a l'air plutôt
optimistes pour cette année même si
évidemment la 10 ans dans la fin de
l'interview il ya des facteurs qu'on ne
contrôle pas pierre tonazzi ni est ce
que c'est votre avis à vous vous avez
plutôt 10 en début d'émission que ces
premiers mois 2016 sont compliquées non
donc son
sont plus compliqué qu'on va dire que la
fin de l'année mais c'est vrai qu'il ya
plusieurs indicateurs qui nous n'aurons
d'autres pistes sur l'avenir donc
surtout soul était donc par exemple les
réservations du japon il était
totalement annulée donc est arrêté pour
trois mois dans toutes été gelés et l'a
finalement la tendance a été renversée
donc on commence à avoir des
réservations du japon donc voilà c'est
c'est plutôt encourageant donc ça c'est
un élément est aussi d'autres
réservation d'autres pays donc savait
que les prospectus sont bons un nouveau
comité sylvie c'est très important
qu'ils aient rien n'arrive encore donc
qu on puisse travailler tranquillement
maintenant surtout la saison estivale
quelques informations apparaissent
maintenant sur les sites yvelinois les
plus visités en 2015 en tête je vous le
disais tout à l'heure
le château de versailles numéro deux le
zoo de thoiry sur la troisième marche
l'île de loisirs de saint quentin et on
trouve ensuite france miniature au
quatrième
on a aussi la bergerie nationale le
château de breteuil la ferme de gally
l'espace rambouillet la serre aux
papillons et les de loisirs du val de
seine on l'a dit dans cette émission
également vous l'avez plusieurs fois
répété les visiteurs des sites heavy
noix sont principalement franciliens
donc des locaux il représente 80% en
moyenne de l'ensemble des visiteurs la
seule exception notable c'est le château
de versailles où là c'est complètement
la verse
est ce que c'est quelque chose que vous
cherchez par exemple modifier vous
messieurs fabrice watts est ce que vous
cherchez aller chercher une clientèle
étrangère pour pour diversifier votre
clientèle et d'augmenter la
fréquentation du site a pour une fois on
va rentrer d'un statistiques 70 pour ce
conte un clientèle de france miniature
sur ces dernières années et francilienne
la difficulté dans la démarche de
d'aller chercher des clients étrangers
c'est qu'en termes de marketing et de
communication sont des coûts énormes et
le gros frein pour notre cas c'est la
possibilité si vous n'êtes pas véhiculer
de venir en france miniature pour des
visiteurs de paris c'est assez compliqué
il faudrait engranger beaucoup de moyens
pour ensuite les envoyer dans une
démarche individuelle assez compliqué
donc non nous on va plutôt clairement
cherché de la clientèle qui est à une
heure du parc qu'elle soit sur l'eure
l'eure-et-loir ou ou sur l'île de france
c'est notre démarche principal les
étrangers qui veulent venir on les
accepte bien volontiers mais non mais on
va peut on démarche peu dans ce sens là
ambroise graffin j'imagine que vous êtes
dans le même temps même constat oui
effectivement c'est à dire la réponse
après tout on se trouve un petit peu je
pense que le même format dire qu'on est
on est un site régional gros sont deux
les gens y viennent qui chante dans un
rayon de 50 kilomètres à peu près c'est
l'ouest parisien et on est sur 50 % de
visiteurs des yvelines et après les
autres départements autour
en revanche en prospection on souhaite
on viserait plus augmenter la part des
visiteurs parisiens ou là ou là une
question de transport aussi parisien
vous attendez de dollars il doit arriver
à ce paris intra muros 75 donc
aujourd'hui c'est ça représente moins de
10% de nos visiteurs et la rambouillet
sa 34e minute de paris bon après il ya
les 5 km a fait entre autres la gare et
et le parc donc là on a en un vrai enjeu
en fait pour essayer de faire venir
beaucoup plus des gens par le train ou
qu'ils soient pas embêté par cette
histoire de notamment de retour en
voiture j'ai pas si vous à la même
problématique
c'est un enjeu important quoi au centre
commercial one nation des
clayes-sous-bois qui rassemble près
d'une centaine de magasins
deluxe vous avez passé des accords avec
des voyagistes japonais chinois et russe
notamment il vous proposer par exemple
une offre visite du château de
versailles et transport pour aller faire
du shopping
ensuite chez vous l'offre peut avoir de
quoi surprendre c'est ça le tourisme de
2002 2016 oui donc aujourd'hui
ce qu'on a pour attirer la clientèle
internationale déjà on a créé ou navette
qui part donc tous les jours des paris
donc silencieuse qu'on a mis en place on
a créé des services pour accueillir nos
clients internationaux et pour faciliter
donc la programmation donc des one fm
paris pour les tour-opérateurs qu'est ce
qu'on a fait on a réuni donc où nos
paquets ge avec le transport de paris on
arrive au château de versailles on
visite le château de versailles avec
antic et coupe-file après on répond de
la navette en viennent à luan méchant
paris ont fait du shopping et après on
rentre à paris toujours avec notre
navette donc c'est vrai que c'est
package facilite la commercialisation
auprès des professionnels tourisme et ça
permet effectivement d augmenter les
parts de marché de la clientèle
internationale au risque on peut
imaginer un partenariat bientôt avec nos
amis
évidemment je pense que raymond et
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on doit faire nous
tous tous les opérateurs dans les
yvelines s'est laissé unis avaient créé
en vraie offre dans les yvelines qu'on a
des l'hôtellerie magnifique on a des
établissements est donc naturel des
établissements culturels donc
extraordinaire donc je pense qu'il faut
vraiment réunir tous ces ensembles des
opérateurs pour faire une offre
touristique et madame nona le sait très
bien donc pour la proposer en france
parce qu'en france c'est quand même en
clientèle très important pour nous et
également à l'international
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
avocate d'avoir participé à ce set 8
sociétés de nous avoir éclairé sur les
enjeux du tourisme
vous pouvez retrouver cette émission en
replay sur tv fil 78 points comme bonne
soirée à tous